STEVE MOULD: I'm Steve Mould.
And I think we should stop using
pi and start using tau.
MATT PARKER: And I'm
Matt Parker.
And I think Steve said
something ridiculous.
I think pi is fantastic.
It's wonderful.
And even if this was an equal
race, we would've been using
both of them.
Or even if tau had been
established first, I'm still
pretty pro-pi.
STEVE MOULD: Wow, that's
quite a claim.
MATT PARKER: Yes, there's
[INAUDIBLE].
STEVE MOULD: So let's
talk about this.
So pi is the circle constant.
It's the constant that
defines a circle.
And the argument is--
MATT PARKER: We're
agreed so far.
[RINGING]
STEVE MOULD: Let's think of a
reasonable definition of what
a circle is.
The classic is all points
equidistant
from a single point.
That distance is the radius.
And if you're ever doing maths
using circles, you talk about
the radius.
All your equations about circles
talk about the radius.
Unless you're an engineer,
you use diameter.
But as a mathematician,
you use the radius.
The circle constant should
surely be defined in terms of
the radius.
[RINGING]
STEVE MOULD: But it isn't pi--
is the circumference
divided by the
diameter, which is crazy.
So the circle constant should
be the circumference divided
by the radius.
When you do that, you
get 2 times pi.
[RINGING]
STEVE MOULD: And so we're not
saying let's redefine pi and
call it 6.28.
But instead--
MATT PARKER: Wow.
STEVE MOULD: --we're saying--
[RINGING]
STEVE MOULD: Shut up.
Instead, we're saying that's
going to be confusing, so
let's invent a new constant.
And we'll call it tau.
MATT PARKER: To be honest, one
of the points was quite nice,
which is that if you're an
engineer, you use pi.
And in fact, historically, we've
used pi because when you
measure a circle, the only
direct measurement you can
make is of the diameter.
[RINGING]
MATT PARKER: And so that's why
historically we've done that.
And to this day in precision
engineering we do that.
And yes, you can do some
very nice maths with
the radius in a circle.
But the only thing
you can directly
measure is the diameter.
So that's why we've used pi.
People say, oh, but we have
to put 2 pi into lots of
equations, and then
blah, blah, blah.
It's always 2 pi.
Why don't we just
use tau instead?
There are as many fantastic
equations out there which use
just the single pi.
And there's no reason
to bring in 2 pi.
[RINGING]
MATT PARKER: And so I see
Steve is holding a pen.
But I have brought my own.
STEVE MOULD: [CHUCKLING].
MATT PARKER: So everyone's
classic is the e to the i pi
job, where e to the i
pi plus 1 equals 0.
[RINGING]
MATT PARKER: And that is
using a solitary pi
out the front there.
And if you want to go
wild, things like
the area of a torus--
this is a nice one-- that
equals pi squared--
[RINGING]
MATT PARKER: --outside the major
radius squared minus the
minor radius squared.
So I'm still doing things
in terms of
radiuses or radii or whatever.
But the pi squared--
that's lovely.
What-- you want 4?
I mean, how you are going to--
STEVE MOULD: Yeah, I want--
MATT PARKER: Tau squared on 4?
STEVE MOULD: What-- yeah,
absolutely-- tau squared on 4.
And I'll explain why.
And this is important.
OK, let's just say that Matt has
cherry-picked a couple of
nice equations there.
Two things I'd say-- let's look
at, for example, the area
of a circle.
So we're looking at the
area pi r squared.
MATT PARKER: That's
just lovely.
Look at that.
[RINGING]
STEVE MOULD: Yeah, OK-- but
here's the problem.
Here's the problem.
If we reframe that in
tau, that would
be tau by 2 r squared.
And you think, OK, that's
less beautiful.
But this tells us something
important.
[RINGING]
STEVE MOULD: This tells
us something.
This is information that you're
obscuring by using pi.
Because you can derive
the area--
MATT PARKER: By simplifying
your--
[RINGING]
STEVE MOULD: No, listen.
You can derive the area of
a circle by integrating.
[RINGING]
STEVE MOULD: So you say, OK,
here's our full circle.
Let's look at the area of this
little strip where the width
of it is delta r.
And this is r going up.
And so this is full
r or whatever.
So you integrate.
The area of this is pi r dr.
MATT PARKER: Tau.
STEVE MOULD: No, but--
sorry, tau, yeah, actually.
[RINGING]
MATT PARKER: See, pi's
just easier to use.
STEVE MOULD: Shut up.
And then you end up with
1/2 tau r squared.
[RINGING]
STEVE MOULD: And so that 1/2
tells you something.
It tells you you've done an
integration to get there.
[RINGING]
STEVE MOULD: And an equation
like this obscures it.
Similarly, with this, if you had
tau squared over 4, that
would tell you something.
This equation here-- let's
just reframe that.
e to the i tau minus
1 equals 0.
[RINGING]
STEVE MOULD: And the great
thing is that is a full
circle, right?
If you want to go through half a
circle, then it's e to the i
tau over 2.
If you want to go a quarter
of a circle, it's e to
the i tau by 4.
[RINGING]
STEVE MOULD: The pi
is confusing.
It's especially confusing
for children when
they're learning as well.
A full circle is 2 pi?
OK, so that half
a circle is pi.
A quarter of a circle
is pi by 2.
So there's always this
factor of 2--
[RINGING]
STEVE MOULD: --that you've got
to keep in your mind when
you're doing calculations.
And actually, if you're a
seasoned mathematician, you're
probably always thinking in
terms of 2 pi, anyway.
[RINGING]
STEVE MOULD: And so let's just
stop thinking in terms of 2 pi
and start thinking
in terms of tau.
MATT PARKER: This is the
hypocrisies of tau.
You want halves here.
You don't want halves
over there.
[RINGING]
STEVE MOULD: I want halves here
because the half tells
you something.
[RINGING]
MATT PARKER: This works
out just as nicely.
Because if you want to
integrate, and you've got your
2 pi r dr, then you
get a wonderful
thing you can simplify.
Because you end up with
this-- r squared--
STEVE MOULD: Yeah, so in
this particular case--
MATT PARKER: --and you
end up with a--
[RINGING]
STEVE MOULD: So in this
particular case--
MATT PARKER: --2 pi and
the 1/2 simplifies.
[RINGING]
STEVE MOULD: Yeah, yeah.
MATT PARKER: Pi r--
that's just--
there's nowhere else in maths
where you say, you know what?
Let's not simplify it.
Let's leave it in a more
complicated form because it--
STEVE MOULD: No, but in fact,
this is the one case where you
think, actually it's useful to
have a 2 there because we can
cancel later.
Most other cases you don't get
to do that cancel because
you're not dividing
by 2 later on.
[RINGING]
STEVE MOULD: In most cases, you
end up with an equation
that's got 2 pi in it.
BRADY HARAN: A lot of smart
people, who I know you
respect-- and I know
you respect the guy
sitting next to you--
STEVE MOULD: [CHUCKLING].
BRADY HARAN: --make the case--
STEVE MOULD: That's correct.
MATT PARKER: Professionally.
BRADY HARAN: A lot of smart
people make the case for tau.
MATT PARKER: Yeah.
BRADY HARAN: How do you explain
their reasoning?
How do you--
I mean, you don't think
Steve's an idiot.
But he has this feeling about
tau that you disagree with.
What's different about his
thinking to yours?
MATT PARKER: You know what?
A lot of people do have very
good arguments for tau.
And a lot of people have very
good arguments for pi.
And there is a wonderful
thing--
I don't know.
I think people like the fact
that it's different and that
they're going, oh, whoa,
whoa, whoa-- everyone
else has got it wrong.
We can change this.
And tau is better.
And oh, people try and
do maths and they
think pi's all that.
No, they're wrong.
But I don't think there's any
great advantage other than it
can be a bit more exclusive to
say, oh, we're all over tau--
[RINGING]
MATT PARKER: --when I
think pi works just
as well in all cases.
It's got the--
I know--
historical--
the fact that it's got a bit
of heritage doesn't mean we
should keep it around
necessarily.
But it's worked for
a very long time.
And it's there for very
good reasons.
[RINGING]
MATT PARKER: Nothing people have
thrown at me in terms of
tau, saying it's better--
you gain as much as
you lose from--
[RINGING]
MATT PARKER: --switching from--
both of them have their
disadvantages and their
advantages.
[RINGING]
MATT PARKER: I don't think
there's enough for an entire
overhaul of the subject because
people think, oh,
what, this particular equation
looks a bit nicer.
Oh, but we've lost the fact that
you get negative numbers
in Euler's identity.
And even your arguments
with circles--
this is my clincher.
This is why I genuinely
think pi is nicer.
If you've got tau, right?
If you do tau radians--
you do an entire revolution--
you end up right back
where you started.
Tau gets you nowhere, right?
[RINGING]
STEVE MOULD: [CHUCKLING].
MATT PARKER: With pi, if you
do pi radians, you actually
get somewhere.
And I think if you want a unit
to measure things, the unit
shouldn't be the whole thing.
[RINGING]
STEVE MOULD: What?
[LAUGHING].
MATT PARKER: A unit should
be a section of it.
And so it's more nuanced.
And for that reason--
STEVE MOULD: Oh, then
in that case--
MATT PARKER: I think
pi is better.
STEVE MOULD: --divide it
by-- you know--360.
[RINGING]
MATT PARKER: Now you've
just gone too far.
No one would use that
kind of a unit.
BRADY HARAN: Steve--
STEVE MOULD: Yeah.
BRADY HARAN: I've heard
you talk a little bit.
And you seem to have an
enjoyment of the history of
mathematics.
Maths is beautiful and pure.
But it's also got
great stories.
STEVE MOULD: Yeah.
BRADY HARAN: Why are you willing
to ditch pi, which is
one of our most important
clinged-to, loved stories?
MATT PARKER: Don't overstate
my case here, all right?
STEVE MOULD: One word--
progress.
[RINGING]
STEVE MOULD: The historical
point is a good one.
[RINGING]
STEVE MOULD: Historically, we
used to sacrifice goats.
[RINGING]
STEVE MOULD: And I think we
should keep doing that.
No--
so you can't just cling to
something because of history.
Having said that, one argument
against tau is that pi is very
well established.
And we'll just never
replace it.
[RINGING]
STEVE MOULD: The strong argument
for me is that tau is
more intuitive.
And so from an educational
point of view--
[RINGING]
STEVE MOULD: --in terms of
understanding circles and
working with circles, tau
makes more sense.
MATT PARKER: Maybe just
call it a circle.
BRADY HARAN: OK, Steve--
MATT PARKER: When you're trying
to teach kids angles,
and you go, what
angle is this?
All of it.
[RINGING]
MATT PARKER: That's just
all the way round.
STEVE MOULD: But then you start
dealing with radians.
MATT PARKER: And then you
get half the circle.
It's called a circle.
BRADY HARAN: Steve, if I made
you education minister of the
world tomorrow, what would you
do about this situation?
STEVE MOULD: Well,
here's the thing.
I think you can actually
slowly bring it in.
Because you can use pi and
tau at the same time.
[RINGING]
STEVE MOULD: Because wherever
you see 2 pi,
you can write tau.
So you don't have
to change any--
you don't have to suddenly
overhaul textbooks and
redefine pi.
You can bring it in slowly.
And so if I was education
minister of the world-- and I
hope to be one day--
you can bring it
in very slowly.
BRADY HARAN: Matt, your argument
seems to be that the
tau people aren't wrong.
It's just a bit needless.
It's extra work--
MATT PARKER: They're
insufficiently right.
[RINGING]
STEVE MOULD: [LAUGHING].
BRADY HARAN: So what's wrong
with education minister for
the world there next to you
slowly bringing in tau?
MATT PARKER: I have no problem
with tau sitting alongside pi.
[RINGING]
MATT PARKER: I have
no problem with--
I think it's very important--
you're right-- to teach
radians in terms of it's a
whole circle, and we're
splitting it up into smaller
amounts, and how it links to
wonderful things like this.
But you never see anyone who's
plugging tau in and going, you
know what, this would
be useful as well.
They're always like,
pi is wrong.
And I'm like, well,
pi is not wrong.
STEVE MOULD: Pi is not wrong.
No, I know.
MATT PARKER: It's perfectly
serviceable.
It's worked a treat.
And it's a wonderful concept.
And I think genuinely it's got
a lot more going for it for
doing maths than tau.
But there's many things where
you could say historically--
like, why don't we
count in base 12?
That would be nicer.
But we don't.
We count in base 10, which, I
admit, I would almost say base
12 has more advantages if we
switch to that than if we
switch to tau.
[RINGING]
MATT PARKER: So why are we
getting so emotional about our
irrationals when we could be a
bit more rational about our
base systems?
BRADY HARAN: I'm stopping
the tape before
you both start talking.
MALE SPEAKER: 4.8 kilograms--
MALE SPEAKER: So we define
angles counterclockwise--
MALE SPEAKER: --of order--
MALE SPEAKER: --so we go that
way rather than that way.
Quite why we do that,
I have no idea.
It's convention.
MALE SPEAKER: And similarly, if
I went up, say, to the size
of a boulder, so
that this was--